operation Hickory the first combat
operation for the third squadron
eleventh Armored Cavalry Regiment on 7
October the squadron deploys near Nam
truck along Highway 15 for two days
while units comb the area only minor
contact is made with the enemy on the
third day a resupply convoy arrives with
food and fuel for the troops during the
break troop commanders discuss
additional search mission but heavy
sniper fire is suddenly encountered from
behind the tree line bordering the
command post as armored vehicles
converge on the area the transfer of
supplies is halted for men and vehicles
alike it's a baptism of fire the heavy
firing continues for 15 minutes before
the snipers guns are finally silent the
resupply operation moves to a new
location but heavy rains have reduced
the terrain to a quagmire
recovery vehicles are brought into play
and this hapless supply truck like
others must be towed onto firmer ground
regrouped in its new location operation
Hickory prepares to resume its Search
and Destroy mission
on 15 octobre a c-130 carrying members
of the first philippine civic action
group sets down a tiny air field 100
kilometers northwest of Saigon the
troops on board are the second
contingent to arrive bringing its total
strength in Vietnam to 2100 men
activated in July the group is
exclusively concerned with economic and
technical assistance to the Vietnamese
in areas recovered from VC control after
an inspection by their commanding
officer the men board trucks bound for
their company area the unit's
capabilities are primarily in
engineering construction and medical
assistance but it is fully armed and
provides its own security in case of
attack upon arrival a briefing is held
on the current mission clearing of an
old Vietcong stronghold the tong Jian
forest for agricultural development by
refugee families in the area first order
of business for the new men however is
setting up a defense perimeter and
living quarters for themselves the
opening of the rich forest lands which
will help to raise the living standards
of thousands of Vietnamese is typical of
the large-scale civic action this unit
will undertake throughout tay ninh
province
the matsu island chain is an integral
part of the taiwan island complex
stronghold of the Republic of China the
matsu chain and the entire Taiwan
complex comprises a heavily armed
fortified landmass virtually a float off
the coast of communist China which is
visible in the distance these scenes of
the red coastline show communist Sam
fans just offshore they were
photographed at a distance of five miles
from Gao dong nearest of the nine matsu
islands on matsu island itself to United
States Army advisors and a nationalist
officer examined holes created by
communist propaganda shell the round is
of Chinese manufacturer and probably was
fired by a russian-made 1 22 millimeter
field gun only 25 meters from where the
shells landed stands the month to
headquarters of the US military
assistance advisory group mag on muscle
is commonly referred to as Mudcat a
contraction of matsu Defense Command
advisor team some of the team's
functions will be explained by its chief
lieutenant colonel charles i white
mudcat has the mission to observe assist
and advise not the defense command on
the use and maintenance of all equipment
in the military assistance program in
addition to monitoring the utilization
of equipment we also frequently check
the training of all types of unions as
team chief I also wanted to the infantry
artillery and the air defense artillery
units within it lots of Defense Command
to accomplish this mission our team
consists in addition to myself an organ
sidh visor a signal advisor three
communicators an administrative
specialist and lastly but not leastly
and navy medic the matsu Defense Command
cadre school on muscle Island is one of
mudcats advisory responsibility
this class on the m1 rifle is part of
the 12-week course that provides
instruction and training in the usual
NCO subjects including weaponry tactics
and leadership bayonet drill and karate
help sharpen these embryo nationalists
noncoms many of whom will be assigned to
units stationed on the other eight
islands in the mat-su complex the mat-su
defense commands highly trained
physically tough and troops are part of
a well-equipped nationalist armed force
that numbers more than 600,000 in the
entire Taiwan complex an ammunition
reconditioning center set up deep within
a cave for security against communist
shelling is another matsu installation
which receives advice from mudcat
maintenance problems on muscle are
compounded by the need to keep ammo in
operational readiness at all times
rather than in storage civic action is
another responsibility of mudcat for two
years team members have been conducting
a twice-weekly physical training program
at the matsu junior middle school
attended by children from all nine
islands while inside the school other
team members conduct English classes
five times a week ok we're off to New
York taxi taxi where to Sir it will take
20 minutes as soon as possible please
please hey please hey hey however it is
with nationalist army personnel but us
advisers devote their most intensive
efforts these scuba divers participating
in a beach landing exercise are members
of an amphibious reconnaissance company
a sign
to the matsu Defense Command as other
members of the company wait offshore the
two scuba divers crawl onto the beach to
make a reconnaissance this exercise is
only one example of the exceptionally
varied training being given to
nationalist soldiers on muscle and mud
cap is hoping to improve the combat
readiness of these already capable
troops at this radio station Mudcat
frequently advises broadcast specialists
under contract to the mat-su Defense
Command here they beam propaganda to the
Chinese mainland what is on your behalf
of a sentence said johanna johanna
johanna should be not only naughty fool
let you guys serious negotiation for
diatomic so many men so if you want war
club scene either the useless then type
or x will fight I mean gender yet you
first walk silly on what can tell you
that you're hot when she comes ah cool
another form of psychological warfare
originating on muscle is the use of
propaganda balloon boxes of leaflets are
attached to some to be released over the
mainland by a timing device scarce items
such as clothing ballpoint pens and
toothpaste are also included in the
propaganda payload soaring across the
Taiwan Straits they are yet another
means of informing people on the
mainland that the free world offers a
more plentiful way of life
on the afternoon of 17 October President
and mrs. Johnson arrived at Honolulu
International Airport on the first leg
of the president's six-nation peace
mission to the Far East amidst the famed
hula dancers of Hawaii and bedecked with
flower leis the President and First Lady
receive a tumultuous welcome in a short
address to the civilian and military
dignitaries and the thousands of
Hawaii's citizens who have come to the
airport to greet him mr. Johnson
expresses his and mrs. Johnson's
appreciation for Hawaii's warm reception
then the presidential motorcade heads
for the east-west Center on the campus
of the University of Hawaii at the
government-sponsored educational center
President Johnson outlines US foreign
policy in Asia and his hopes for the
future I go to Asia with confidence and
with hope behind the terrible cost
combat and hostility I believe that a
new area is gradually coming into its
own the process is slow but the signs
are unmistakable one after another the
nations of Asia are testing off the
sprint slogans of earlier National
Marrow nationalism one after another the
nations of Asia are grasping the
realities of an interdependent Asia of
what are these realities but the
security of every nation is threatened
by impact on any nation that national
stability and strength can only come
through self-help Riddler's planning
hard work and sacrifice
that political power help of the fuel
and the rich within a nation is power
that will not loan survive that lasting
national prosperity can only come
through full cooperation with one's
neighbors the rich and the poor the
large and the small alike that no single
nation can or should be permitted to
dominate the Pacific region that
disputes settled by other than peaceful
means our disputes that will remain
unsettled most important of all that
Asia's destiny lies in the hands of
asians themselves some are later the
pragmatic and the compassion spirit of
the Chinese people will prevail over
outmoded dogmatism and we in America
look to that day with open with
confidence and for our part we shall do
what we can to hasten its coming we
shall keep alive the hope for a pure
flow of ideas and people between
mainland China and the United States as
I have fed so recently on so many other
occasions for only throw such exchange
can isolation be ended and then
suspicion give way to trust we do not
believe in eternal enmity are listed
among nations must ultimately end in
reconciliation and we heart too little
it to the day when the policies of
mainland China will offer and will
permit such a reconciliation but we are
not prepared to pay for peace the price
of freedom we shall never surrender
American freedom are sacrificed the
freedom of America's allies
in asia early the following morning 18
October mr. and mrs. Johnson arrived at
Hickam Air Force Base and depart for
American Samoa several hours later the
presidential jet arrives at the Pongo
Pongo airport in the american territory
of samoa the President and First Lady
are met by territorial governor rex lee
a presidential appointee as a school
band plays KO to the chief also on hand
to greet the president or twenty Samoan
tribal chiefs and royal ladies who
present shell laws to the visitors as
the chief executive in the first lady
mount the speaker's platform almost the
entire population of 26,000 is on the
scene the President thanked the Samoans
for their loyalty and support following
the brief address comes the royal of a
ceremony in which the juice of a bitter
sacred route is sipped by both the High
Chief of 22 ela and President Johnson
pouring off the evil spirit part of the
potion mr. Johnson drinks to fellowship
with a royalty of some off the tour Lolo
or gift-giving ceremony is next and
precious handmade items are brought
forth among the exotic presidential
gifts is an exquisite handcrafted royal
tapa cloth made from beaten mulberry
bark and died with root dies native
roast pig the feast dish of the Samoans
and other Polynesians is resplendent on
a presentation litter at the conclusion
of the welcoming ceremonies the Johnsons
dedicate a new school as Lady Bird cuts
a garland of flowers officially opening
the new educational facility for the
children of Americans amor touring the
new school which was named the ladybird
consolidated school the Johnsons
observed the latest Educational
Television techniques teaching by TV has
proven highly successful in some or most
teachers are missionaries following
their visit to the school president and
mrs. Johnson depart to continue their
tour of the Pacific and Asia next stop
is New Zealand 1,600 miles to the
southwest by 1630 hours the following
day 19 October the presidential party is
arriving at Wellington Airport aboard a
royal new zealand air force dc-6 after a
short hop from their landing point at co
hoc KO military base New Zealand's
governor-general Brigadier Sir Bernard
Ferguson greets the Johnsons thousands
of New Zealanders turn out for the
ceremonies after a short speech of
appreciation President Johnson inspects
the honor guard of the Commonwealth a
motorcade carries the presidential party
to government house where the Johnsons
are honored overnight guests of the
governor-general the following day 20
octobre the president has taken on a
ceremonial tour of New Zealand's
national war memorial and parliament
house on Route some citizens of the
British Commonwealth nation expressed
displeasure over the Vietnam War but
there are many supporters of President
Johnson's policies as well and his
welcome is enthusiastic and warm
surrounded by members of the parliament
mr. Johnson visits VAT historic building
the whirlwind tour of Wellington
continues as President Johnson comes to
the Civic Square here the chief
executive is greeted by Wellington's
mayor sir francis kits and Lady kits a
host of City dignitaries cram the
reception line as
thousands of New Zealanders look on
strolling through the square with Mayor
kits the president pauses to admire the
beautiful tulip bed as a military band
plays Moon River the president's visit
to New Zealand concludes the Johnsons
board US Air Force One and resumed their
travels as they head for Australia and
the rest of the president's tour of Asia
at one of the largest army installations
in the south Fort Benning Georgia Air
Force pilots of the 44 49th combat crew
training squadron are being trained by
the army to fly an army aircraft the cv
to caribou this unusual program results
from a joint airlift agreement under
which the Air Force acquires the Army's
entire caribou fleet about 130 planes
most of which are located in Southeast
Asia the all-weather caribou carries
about the same load as a c-47 and has a
three-man crew aircraft commander pilot
and flight mechanic after this group of
Air Force pilots complete the four-week
course some will become instructors and
remain at Fort Benning to Train caribou
pilots for the Air Force a member of an
army Pathfinder unit calls in clearance
and a caribou comes in for a low Lex or
low-level extraction drop this technique
is similar to LA PE s the low altitude
parachute extraction system used by the
Air Force moving upstairs the Air Force
planets check out in heavy equipment
drops by the end of this year when the
Caribous will be officially transferred
to the Air Force the tax squadron at
Fort Benning will have trained in
combat-ready flight crews to man them
at Fort Belvoir Virginia a boat powered
by water jet instead of conventional
propellers is being extensively tested
by the army mobility equipment centers
rmd laboratory designed to increase
mobility in swamps and shallow waters
the fully loaded craft can move at 20
miles an hour over water only 9 inches
deep with lighter loads it can make up
to 30 miles an hour driven by a gasoline
engine the propulsion unit forces out a
powerful jet of water beneath the
surface a special weed cutting mechanism
prevents fouling and permits operation
in waters clogged with vegetation
because there are no propellers men and
equipment can be landed on shallow water
beaches
to top it off the aluminum hull craft
weighs only 3,400 pounds light enough
for transport by helicopter